This episode is gifted to you with limited commercial interruption by Macy's. Shop now at macy's.com slash gift guide. It's the sweetest time of the year. Valentine's Day is approaching and Macy's has the best of the best gifts for your loved ones. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Here's what I love about Macy's. It really has a little something for everyone. This Valentine's Day, I got my husband the most romantic gift ever. I got him a set of Tupperware.
But hear me out. He really loves having nice Tupperware. He bakes a lot. He is a baker and a chef. And I went to Macy's home section, and they had amazing Tupperware. So I got him a set of that and then while I was there I also got him a new skillet.
He's going to be so happy and Josh I know you listen to the podcast so sorry. Now you know. But you know Macy's truly has everything you need at such great price points. Shop Macy's gift guides for the perfect hand picked items for everyone on your list. This Valentine's Day let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Shop in-store or online at macy's.com slash gift guide. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Lovers Podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews by our best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details
and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi, happy Wednesday. Hi, Jenna is giddy. She is giddy. She is giddy. She's like, you're actually like blushing, like, cause you're so like, I feel like you have a body buzz right now.
Well, everyone, this Friday is Valentine's Day. And Angela, you have given me the greatest Galentine's Day gift of our friendship. I guess I have. I was thinking of like all the gifts we've exchanged over the years, this might be your favorite. It might be. Should we tell them what it is?
Please. Okay, well, you guys, we went into the Dear Office Lady's mailbag and a lot of you wrote in saying that I should watch The Edge. Thank you, thank you for writing that. Emma Grace from Texas, will you please add The Edge to your movie list to break down on the podcast?
I watched it because of Jenna, it's one of my all time favorites, she's right. It is so inspirational. It is Emma, it is. We got several letters like this lady, and you know what? You did watch the Star Wars Christmas special for me. I did. You did. You technically watched a Star Wars movie ish. Well so for this Valentine's my gift to you is I said let's break down the edge
lady let's do it. This was the most amazing work week for me, Angela. I got to watch my favorite movie for work. I know, you kept texting me, this is my work day. And it would just be a screenshot of like a bear in the woods. Well I got so excited I said we should even bring back Fast Facts, so I say let's get to it. Let's do it. All right, The Edge, written by David Mamet, Pulitzer Prize and Tony-winning playwright, he's also a director
and screenwriter. He is a master of dialogue and the dialogue in this movie is fantastic. This film is directed by Lee Tomahore from New Zealand. His directorial debut was Once Were Warriors, which was a huge critical success. It won many, many awards and was the highest grossing film in New Zealand of all time. Wow. That's right. And he also directed huge hits like Mulholland Falls, Boys on the Side.
Let's jump into Fast Fact number one. The Edge is one hour and 57 wonderful minutes. It was released September 26, 1997. It had a budget of $30 million and it made 43.3 million at the worldwide box office. Here is your cast. Anthony Hopkins plays billionaire Charles Morse. Alec Baldwin is handsome photographer Bob Green.
Harold Perrineau is Bob's photography assistant, Steven, you might know him from Lost. He played Michael Dawson in Lost, he's so good in it. So good. He's also in two Matrix movies, you guys. Oh, so you liked this. Uh-huh. Okay, this is great, this is good.
And then finally, rounding out the cast is Elle McPherson as billionaire Charles Morris's wife, supermodel Mickey Morse. And you know Elle McPherson is a real life supermodel. Here's a fact for you. The original title of this movie was Bookworm. But about three months before the movie was set to come out, the studio decided that it needed a more commercial title.
Something that really spoke to the suspense of the film. I think I agree with them. I agree. The role of Bob Green, played by Alec Baldwin, was originally offered to Harrison Ford and Dustin Hoffman. What? Could you imagine?
No. Dustin Hoffman as Bob? As Bob. Well, I, no, I can't. I also read that Robert De Niro showed some interest in the role of billionaire Charles Morse, but that it went to Anthony Hopkins. I literally can't imagine anyone else in these roles.
Yeah, yeah, it's hard to picture it. All right, fast fact number two. This film was shot in Alberta, Canada. It was shot between August and November 1996 in Banff National Park, Canmore, Edmonton, Thunderstone Quarries and Fortress Mountain Resort. And here is an audio clip of director Lee Tomahawry talking about the location. We really needed to take this film somewhere that people haven't really been before. So it needed to look very, very rugged.
You can't really fight that. You've got to take the actors and everybody into this environment. Give me your best, fair confrontation. You're lost right in the heart of the wilderness. You've got to know how to survive. What I like about all of David Mamet's work is that it's extremely primal.
It's one guy pitted against another guy, two guys pitted against the wilderness. When you take actors, the likes of Tony, who's never been exposed to this type of harrowing location, it braces them up more. So lady, they were really out there. The actors, the crew, in the wilderness. I want to paint a little picture for you. The temperatures in Banff National Park in August are a high of 62 and a low of 33.
But when we get to November, the high is 24 degrees and the low is three. Yeah, that's not a lot. Josh went on a hiking trip with his college buddies there and absolutely loved it, but it is rugged terrain. Yes. These fellas spend a lot of time in water. I check the seawater temperatures. In August, they're around 54 to 61 degrees. For reference, I keep my cold dip tank around 60 degrees. I sit in it for one minute and I go pretty numb in about 30 seconds.
In November, the water gets as low as like 50 degrees and they really got in it. Like that wasn't like a sound stage or something. They just- They look cold. And they don't warm the water. Obviously it's sea water, it's water, it's natural water. You can't warm a park, lake.
Correct. Yeah, they're in it. They're in it. All right, well, I've told you the characters, I've told you the location, Angela. Fast Fact Three, over to you. Yeah, I took Fast Fact Three and I'm gonna give you two movie reviews
and one of the original movie trailers. So people either really love this movie or they're like, eh, meh about it. Yes, I know this, you know this. No one hates it though. There might be one or two. I don't think so. I only chose reviews that came out in 1997.
Great, when the movie came out. This is from Real Views, real is spelled R-E-E-L. Their movie reviewer James Berardonelli gave it two stars and said the following, frankly even though the edge is almost always dumb, it's also often fun. And to give the film its due, it's never boring. On the rare occasion when the plot goes for character development, the performances of Hopkins and Baldwin carry it through. The cinematography is frequently breathtaking and Jerry Goldsmith's score has enough majesty to highlight the impressive vistas. This film includes several memorable moments and also The Edge can boast what is hands down the best anti-lawyer line of the year.
I'm gonna bring it up when we get to it. However, just like creamy icing can't save a half-baked cake, these positive elements can't hide the fact that the Edge is a bad movie. That's a two-star review from James. What does he need the filmmakers to do? Come and literally suck a dick? How do I get two more stars? Majesty, cinematography, amazing performances, wonderful dialogue? What else do you need while you're watching this movie, James? A literal blowjob? What do you need? Don't come for my movie. Oh my gosh. This is like maybe the most hostile I've ever heard you on the podcast.
All right, the next review, I'm only giving you two from 1997. The next one is from Roger Ebert, who gave it three out of four stars. Yes, Roger Ebert, established movie critic. Jinnah, you don't know James. I know James. Okay.
I know enough about James that it's all I need to know. Roger wrote a very long review. I can put a link to it. But here are the highlights. He says about the edge, it's subtly funny in the way it toys with the cliches of the genre. Too subtle apparently for some. Like James. The movie contains glorious scenery, quixotic,
mammoth conversations, and of course the obligatory action scenes. Even in generating tension, the movie toys with convention. There are a few bare wrestling matches and a big showdown with the beast, but the movie doesn't lose its mind and go berserk with action in the last half hour, as most action films seem to. It is typical of Mamet that he could devise his plot in such a way that the climactic payoff would not be bloodshed, but the simple exchange of a wristwatch. Thank you, Roger Ebert. Thank you Roger Ebert. It also got 62% on Rotten Tomatoes tomato meter and 70% on the popcorn meter which is the fan ranking.
Maybe I shouldn't have read the reviews. There's nothing you can say about my movie. I'm not saying it. I will ever, ever stray from my love for it. I am reading other people's words. All right. And I also thought we should hear one of the original movie trailers for The Edge. It's that classic trailer. Remember how in the 90s they all had the same voice
over actor who would like say things like, in a world, like that? I loved it so much. It has a fantastic ending line. Let's hear it. You're the salt of the earth. You're the most excellent man. That's why I married you. And you're the only woman I've ever wanted. Stephen, lucky girl you are. A billionaire who has everything he wants. To a good companion, a good friend, and a good sport. Got it. Okay, great.
A photographer who wants everything he has. Nice looking lady. Your wife? Yes. Why'd you ask? Just like to know who everybody is Must be tough all that money. They're knowing what people value you for what you value me for Bob. I think you're pretty cute So Are you planning to kill me? Now, two rivals lost in the wilderness are forced to confront nature.
What do we got to do? Am I supposed to have a plan? What they're about to discover You got it, Chuck! Nature isn't as dangerous as the nature of man. Academy Award winner Anthony Hopkins You wanna die out here? I'm not gonna die.
Alec Baldwin Money folk, sit up there, drink some golf. You make me sick. Where civilization ends, survival begins. Come and get me. The Edge. I mean, isn't that a great trailer? Yeah, because it's from a great movie. You really, you know, they had good film to work with
when they made that trailer. Let James go, let him go. You know what? All right, I'll let him go. Let him go, because where civilization ends, survival begins. I'm so excited. Angela, I loved your fast fact.
I love everything about The Edge. Why don't we take a break, and then we can start breaking down the edge. And thanks to Macy's, we only have to take one break this episode. Thank you, Macy's. This segment is brought to you by Macy's. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Well, you know, we've been talking about how the folks
at Dunder Mifflin would spend Valentine's Day, and we have some more for you. Yes, and Cassie, you helped us with these. They are so funny. You pitched that Daryl would want the night to be super romantic, so he would probably take his date to a piano bar and like get on stage and serenade her. I think you are so right. And then you also said in the end
they might end up feeding their leftovers to some squirrels on the way home, which I loved. I like to imagine that their leftovers are just like types of mixed nuts, trail mix. What are they eating? Well, I guess if they were at a piano bar, maybe. Maybe some peanuts. Well, you know, they were at a piano bar, maybe. Maybe some peanuts. Well, you know, we were wondering, what would Meredith do? And Cassie said she thinks she would go to a rock concert and then probably end up getting
kicked out and then just hook up with her date in her minivan. I think that tracks. Yes, she finds her date on Valentine's Day. At the rock concert. Yes. Stanley would definitely keep things low key. I think he's doing a couples massage or maybe he has to go from one couples massage
to another couples massage. Oh no. He's in two different couples, right? Yes. Stanley is spending a lot of money on Valentine's Day. Sure is. And I think we all know that he's gonna end his Valentine's Day in a bubble bath
with a glass of red wine. He comments on that frequently. Yeah. Well, you know, he's gonna end his Valentine's Day in a bubble bath with a glass of red wine. He comments on that frequently. Yeah. Well, you know, he could pick up some nice bath accessories from Macy's. He could have a whole spa night. I gave my sister some really nice bath towels from Macy's for Christmas. They're really nice. Oh, yeah. They have a great home section.
I got Josh a whole set of Tupperware from Macy's. Oh. Not so much a bath thing. Yeah. Well, you know who could use that? Kevin, for his leftover chili. That's right. Mm-hmm.
I was thinking about Dwight and Valentine's Day. And here's my thoughts. Whatever you do for Valentine's Day, don't be a Dwight. Do not get your partner a feral barn cat named garbage. Instead, go to Macy's. Macy's is your one- stop shop for Valentine's Day. So as you gear up for the big day of love, if you start to feel yourself thinking like Dwight, do not.
Just stop it. Yes, don't do that. Go to Macy's. You know that we are huge supporters of Macy's all year long because they make shopping so simple for every occasion. They have amazing gift guides with hand-picked gifts for everyone on your list. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting.
Shop in store or online at macy's.com slash gift guide. We are back, are you ready? I'm ready. Here we go. We open on a small airplane. Lady, what? I have to share something with you. What? I know everyone talks about the bear in this movie. Yes. But I need to point something out right away. What is it? It's in the opening credits. What is it? It is something that continues throughout the movie. Okay. And it literally chilled me to the bone. What? It was so unsettling. The very beginning of the movie, before you see anything on the screen, the screen is just gray and you hear wind. But it's that wind that's like cold out in the wilderness kind of wind.
Shhhhhh. Yeah, for like two minutes, it's just wind. Wind is throughout the whole movie. I would like to say that one of the other big characters in this movie is the wind. Oh, I like that. The atmosphere. Yes, it creeped me out just in the very beginning.
Oh, my goodness. So you hear all the wind, right? And then finally out of the gray, you see a small plane. It's kind of a fancy like private plane. And it lands and everyone exits off the plane. Yeah, people get off the plane, and they're about to get on another plane. Mickey has a lot of Louis Vuitton luggage.
I just wanted to point that out. Oh, does she? Well, yes, and this is when we're gonna learn who everyone is. We're gonna learn that Charles is a billionaire. We're also gonna learn that he is used to people like coveting his wife. There's a mechanic who's like,
I would love to get my hands on her, and he's like, on who? And he's like, the plane. It's a $20 million plane called the Challenger. Yeah, but of course he thought the guy was talking about his supermodel wife. Right. It probably happens to him all the time.
Right. And he was kind of looking in her direction. Yeah. Yeah. So they're going from their private plane to this little private water plane. And we're gonna get a lot of foreshadowing here. We're gonna hear the pilot say, hey, everything's fine. He says, just don't fly under any low ceilings.
You don't want a bird strike. You don't want migrating birds to run into your plane. Yeah, because they could take the plane down. Exactly. We also learned, like Charles has an assistant, who gives him like a manila envelope. He also says he checked out the plane and that it's safe. And then he says, when do you think you'll require
your big fancy plane back? And Bob, who's played by Alec he says, when do you think you'll require your big fancy plane back? And Bob, who's played by Alec Baldwin, says, I want the film in New York, 36 hours. I'd say 8 o'clock tomorrow night. Lady, I'm confused. What? Did they go all this way for just one night? I think so. That's crazy.
Yeah, they're there because Bob is doing a photo shoot with Mickey. Right. And I guess they let Charles tag along. He's taken a day off to join her. They are because Bob is doing a photo shoot with Mickey. Right. And I guess they let Charles tag along. He's taken a day off to join her. She's so excited. Right, okay. Well, before we get to the scene in the prop plane,
I thought, well, lady, I tried to be Dr. Thibodeau. Oh. And track some stuff. What'd you track? Well, here are my Dr. Thibodeau stats. And Dr. Thibodeaux, I apologize, they are not as thorough as yours. But the name Charles is said 118 times in the movie.
So many times, they say each other's names so many times. 118 times, you're gonna hear Charles. The name Bob is said 27 times. Oh. The word bear is said 19 times. The word shit is said 19 times. Oh. The word bear is said 19 times. The word is said 19 times. Oh, I didn't even catch that. The word is said 13 times. Wow. And the word mother is said twice. Wow. There are your doctor tibetostats. Charles Charles Charles. What do you think Charles Charles Charles. What are we doing next Charles. Yeah. he does say it a lot.
So now what happens is this, more foreshadowing, this little prop plane takes off without incident. Charles is gonna open up his envelope that he got from his assistant to see that it is a wrapped gift. It is a book called Lost in the Wilds by D. Crowley. And I looked it up, it's not a real book. If it was a real book, I would have wanted it for sure.
Well, I was very curious about this book as well. And I found a blog about it written by David Crowley, if we're saying that last name correctly, and listen to this. David writes, after the movie came out, a lot of fans went looking to pick up a copy of the book. A task which was made particularly challenging because it didn't really exist. The book was a prop made for the movie. There were three copies made for the filming, one of which was lost after the shot where it slowly sinks to the bottom of
the lake. Here's the tidbit that I loved, lady. David writes, the book's author is shown clearly on the cover as Dee Crowley, which is in fact my name. But in this case, it was a tip of the hat to director Lee Tamahori's assistant, Dara Crowley. Dara is my sister. And after filming was completed, my sister kindly sent me one of the two remaining copies of the book for my birthday.
Wow! I knew nothing about them at the time, so it was a fun surprise. She included a note with it joking that we had been published, which was written on stationery with the movie's working title of Bookworm. Isn't that so fun? That is so, so cool. And a little bit like you said, foreshadowing, the first chapter that Charles opens up to
says traps and snares. Well another thing we're gonna learn here is that the reason Charles's assistant gave him this book is that it is a birthday gift. Yes. No one else is regarding this day as his birthday. It kinda seems like everyone else forgot and only his assistant remembered.
Miss Harriet Smith. Yes. But this is when the other passengers start chatting and one of the gals on the plane who's part of this whole like photography shoot, she notices that Bob, played by Alec Baldwin, has a new watch. It has dual time zones.
Yeah. I looked up the watch, because this is gonna come back later, this watch everybody. There's this guy who has a YouTube channel called the Timeless Watch Channel, and he did a mini series that looks at how watches play significant roles in movies.
Oh. He did a whole deep dive on why do protagonists wear their watches with the clock facing in and the strap facing out. He noted that this is true of Alec Baldwin in this movie. It is true in Die Hard and in John Wick. All of the leads of the movies, their watches, which figure significantly to the plot,
are always facing in. We know why. The camera angle? Yeah, because when you're doing takes, if the watch kept moving, it would be a different time every time. So if your watch is gonna play a big role in the movie, you put the band facing out.
So you can pick when to show it and make sure it's the correct time. Exactly. Exactly. I will also tell you that the watch is a Seamaster chronograph watch, which goes for around $5,000. This is a nice watch, everybody. I was really curious about that because, you know, we ultimately see the receipt for the watch and it said
$2,700. Well, nowadays, $5,000. Wowzers. Mm-hmm. Well, you know, we learned something really quickly, I feel like, about Bob in this scene is that everyone thinks he's hilarious. Because when he says, I don't have to go through the anguish of adding three hours, you know, because he has LA and New York on his watch, everyone laughs like so hard. Like this is the funniest thing. I don't think Bob's funny. Oh, I think Bob's a douchebag. Yeah.
Yeah, we would not like Bob at a party. We would not like Bob. The plane is now gonna fly over some snowy mountains. It lands on the water. It pulls up to a dock, this beautiful rustic lodge. This is where they're gonna shoot their amazing photograph tomorrow. Elle MacPherson said in an interview
that that lodge was built for the movie and then taken down afterward. No way. Yes. It's massive. I know, and beautiful. She was like, I would have bought it and lived there if someone would have told me.
She said it was amazing. It was just a set. Wow. Not real. Well, did you catch the dialogue as they're walking up the steps? You know, you've got the crusty old guy styles, right? And Mickey says to him,
so you built this place with your own hands? And he says, yes ma'am, been building it all my life. His whole life. What? We also learned that there's no locks on any of the doors and the bedrooms and outhouses are upstairs. I'm sorry, what? Outhouses?
What, they have to go to the bathroom outside? I don't know, but later on in the evening when it's time to go to bed, like a generator shuts off all of the electricity and Charles has to walk around with a lantern. I have stayed somewhere like that. I stayed in this rustic cabin with a generator. It literally shut down at nightfall. We had no electricity. I don't know.
Seems like you wanted to go on at nightfall. I know. Right? I can use the sun during the day. Maybe at night, maybe we flip it? Yeah, I think that would be smart. I don't know. I don't want to tell people how to run their old lodges.
All right, let me give you a quick summary of what's gonna happen now. Bob is gonna see a black and white photo of an indigenous man holding a rifle and he tells his assistant, Stephen, this is what I want, I want this guy for tomorrow. But you can never get a guy like this because these guys don't exist anymore, right?
This authenticity in this picture. Yeah. And of course, Styles, the runner of the Lodge, is like, I took that picture last year. Yeah. He's my friend. Yeah. Krusty Styles is what I call him. Krusty Styles.
He looks like he has like a big, like kind of like maybe he got in a tussle with a bear at some point. Oh, he's got scars. Yeah. Yeah. He's Krusty Styles. He's worn in. Yeah.
He knows this guy. Jack Hawks is his name. Yeah. He's crusty styles. He's worn in. Yeah. He knows this guy. Jack Hawks is his name. And Bob really wants to meet him. Can we just comment one second that Bob is wearing almost like a full length black leather coat.
Is he? Yeah. Douche Bob number two. Yeah. Tracking Douche Bob. Charles's first stop is to go over to the bookshelf. This guy loves books. Remember the movie was called Bookworm.
There's books but there's also like a whole shelf of National Geographic magazines. Yeah. This is when Mickey says Charles knows everything. You can ask him any question. I bet you can't stump him. Yeah. So Krusty Stiles says, I'll give you five dollars to tell me what's on the other side of this paddle. It's like a canoe paddle up on the wall and it has a carving in it. Yeah. And the side he can see is like a black jaguar, like black panther looking animal, right?
Yeah, and Charles says, it's a rabbit smoking a pipe. And then, Krusty Styles flips over the paddle and it is. Yes, it is a traditional motif of the Cree Indian tribe. The rabbit is the prey, but is unafraid of the Cree Indian tribe. The rabbit is the prey but is unafraid of the panther because he's smarter than the panther. Yeah so you know everyone's very impressed except for Bob and another thing I track throughout this movie is something I call Bob snark. A lot of snark from Bob. A lot of snark from Bob. He looks at him with kind of like that, like stink eye
and goes, amazing accomplishment. Yeah. He's not impressed. Well, now it's time to go to bed and Stiles says, listen, go to bed, but I gotta tell you, it's like time for bears, beware of the bears. Lady, he literally says, we got a problem with bears around here.
And just so you guys know, that's where I'm out. I'm out. I'm packing up my shit and I'm leaving. If you tell me we got a problem with bears around here, that's it, enjoy your weekend, I'm gone. Well, Stiles says don't leave food out. Never leave food out. Not even inside.
Yeah. And then he says, you know, if a bear does come upon you, stand still. And then back away slowly. He says, let the bear know you see him. Yeah. What am I making eye contact with a bear? I'm out, Krusty Styles, I'm out.
Mickey says, well, on that note, I'm going to bed. And then she has a little flirty moment with Bob. Bob whispers something in her ear and she like bats him away. Yeah, she like shoves him and is like, shut up. But Charles sees it all. Oh yeah. Well now Mickey and Charles are up in their bedroom, right?
And Charles is like, hey, do you know why my secretary gave me this book? We're going to bed now. And he's basically saying like, this is my birthday. Are you gonna remember my birthday? He says, you know, this is a very special day for me. Mm-hmm. Dot, dot, dot.
Yeah. And she says can you make me a sandwich? Right. What? So Charles goes downstairs in the dark with his lantern. Mm-hmm. He goes in the kitchen. This kitchen is so freaking cool. He notices someone left some ham out.
There's like a whole honey baked ham. And the door is open and you hear that wind. And I'm like, oh, I was on the edge of my seat. The edge? The edge. Yeah, you were. And guess what? He makes a sandwich really quick. It looks good too.
Every time I see him make the sandwich, he does it with such care. He really did put love in it. Yeah, he loves her. Yeah, and he's walking out of the kitchen with this little sandwich on this plate, didn't clean up his stuff. That's okay.
Left the mayo out. Didn't put the ham away. Didn't put the ham away. Didn't put any of the food away. No. Krusty Styles rule number one. Yeah, but he walks out of the kitchen and there is a giant bear. Yeah, I screamed out loud. Yeah. But he walks out of the kitchen and there is a giant bear. Yeah. I
screamed out loud. Yeah. I screamed. I don't know. Did anyone else scream at this moment, Sam? Cassie? My cat was laying on my lap and at this moment when the bear screamed, she leapt a foot into the air and ran out of the room and has never done that before. Oh my gosh. I'm so sorry. That's so like primal. Yes. She's like predator, I'm out. Exactly. I screamed out loud.
大声尖叫。对。我尖叫了。我不知道。大家刚才有尖叫吗，萨姆？卡西？我的猫当时正趴在我腿上，在熊尖叫的那一刻，它吓得跳了一英尺高，跑出了房间，它以前从来没这样过。噢天哪。我很抱歉。这太像本能反应了。是的。它就像是在说，有捕食者，我溜了。没错。我当时大声尖叫了。
Holy crap. Well guess what? It's a prank. Surprise. He's not a real bear. Happy birthday. Bob was dressed in like a bear skin. Like he took the rug off the ground
天呐。好吧，你猜怎么着？是个恶作剧。惊喜。他才不是真正的熊。生日快乐。鲍勃身上套着像是熊皮的东西。就像他把地上的地毯拿起来
and wrapped it around him. Exactly. And you know what? I call bulls**t. What? This is a s**tty surprise birthday. He could have had a heart attack. He looks like he's gonna have a heart attack.
披在身上一样。没错。你知道吗？我觉得太扯了。什么？这算什么烂生日惊喜。他本来可能会心脏病发作的。他看起来快要心脏病发了。
And behind Bob is everybody. They've got a cake. They're like, surprise, happy birthday. A cake, by the way, that no one eats. Did you notice that? Of course. No one eats the cake. No one eats the cake. No one eats the cake.
鲍勃身后站着所有人。他们拿着一个蛋糕。他们说，惊喜，生日快乐。顺便说一句，这个蛋糕根本没人吃。你们注意到了吗？当然。没人吃蛋糕。没人吃蛋糕。没人吃蛋糕。
This birthday lasts maybe four minutes. They give them two presents and then they're like, good night. Good night. Don't eat the cake. Leave it out. Leave out the honey baked ham and the mayo. What the hell? I know.
这个生日差不多只持续了四分钟。他们送了两个礼物，然后就说，晚安。晚安。别吃蛋糕。把它留在那。把蜜汁烤火腿和蛋黄酱留在那。搞什么鬼？我知道。
Earlier you said you would go home. My notes for this movie, I wrote, this is when I would leave. It's a terrible prank to pre-empt somebody. Terrible! So awful. Yeah, and I also wrote, who are these people to Charles? I mean, he's spending his birthday with these people that clearly, other than his wife, they don't give a f*** about him.
你刚才说你会回家。我为这部电影写的笔记里写道，这就是我会离开的时候。对一个毫无准备的人搞这种恶作剧太糟糕了。太糟糕了！太恶劣了！对，我还写道，这些人对查尔斯来说算什么？我的意思是，他跟这群人一起过生日，除了他老婆之外，很显然这些人根本不在乎他。
No. He is going to get two gifts. He is going to get a watch. He is going to get a Hamilton pocket watch. Yes, an engraved gold pocket watch. From his wife. I found them on eBay. They cost anywhere from 500 to $2,000. Remember how much Bob's watch was?
没错。他将收到两件礼物。他将收到一块表。他将收到一块汉密尔顿怀表。是的，一块刻字的金色怀表。他妻子送的。我在eBay上看到过。它们的价格在500到2000美元之间。还记得鲍勃的表多少钱吗？
Yeah, yeah. Okay. So. It's engraved and it says to my beloved husband on his birthday from the luckiest woman in the world. I have an observation about Mickey. What is it? She has a lot of grandiose statements. Yeah.
对，对。好吧。所以。上面刻着字，写着“送给我挚爱的丈夫，祝他生日快乐，来自世界上最幸运的女人”。我对米奇有个观察。是什么？她有很多浮夸的言论。对。
You're perfect, I'm the luckiest, we're the most wonderful. Anyway, Bob gives Charles a pocket knife and then Stiles says, well, you better give him a coin. And I was curious about this. It's a thing. It's like an old superstition. Have you never done this?
你太完美了，我是最幸运的，我们是最棒的。不管怎样，鲍勃送给查尔斯一把折叠刀，然后斯泰尔斯说，嗯，你最好回送他一枚硬币。我对这个挺好奇的。这是个讲究。这就像是一个古老的迷信。你从来没这样做过吗？
No. What? No one's given me a superstition. Have you never done this? No. What? No one's given me a knife before. I guess when I got married, I got a set of knives, but I didn't send a bunch of pennies to people. When I got married, I got a set of knives, and the person taped a penny on the box of knives. And I guess I was supposed to take the penny
没有。什么？没有人给过我关于迷信的东西。你从来没这样做过吗？没有。什么？以前没有人送过我刀。我想我结婚的时候收到过一套刀，但我没有给别人寄过一堆便士。我结婚的时候收到过一套刀，那个人在刀盒上用胶带贴了一枚便士。我想我是应该拿走那枚便士
and then send it back to them. I don't think I did. And I also don't know who gave them to me and I might not talk to them anymore. Oh well maybe then you should have done it. Yeah tell us about it Ange. I know this. Okay. The tradition of giving a knife as a gift is accompanied by an old but intriguing superstition. That knife could symbolically cut the ties between the giver and the receiver, potentially ending love or severing the bond. To counteract this, a long-standing custom involves including a coin with the gift. Historically, even a simple penny suffices. The recipient then
然后把它寄还给他们。我觉得我当时没这么做。而且我也不知道是谁送给我的，我可能再也不跟他们联系了。哦，好吧，那也许你当时真该照做。是啊，跟我们说说吧，安吉。我知道这个。好吧。赠送刀具作为礼物的传统伴随着一个古老但有趣的迷信。那把刀可能会象征性地割断赠送者和接收者之间的联系，潜在地终结爱情或切断羁绊。为了抵消这一点，一个长期存在的习俗是在礼物中包含一枚硬币。从历史上看，甚至一枚简单的便士就足够了。然后收礼人将
returns the penny to the giver, symbolically buying the knife, which is believed to maintain the bond between them. Yep. So there you go. And he does. Charles gives Bob a coin. Yes. I also wanted to point out how beautiful this pocket knife is.
便士退还给送礼人，象征性地买下这把刀，人们相信这能维持他们之间的羁绊。没错。所以就是这样。他确实这么做了。查尔斯给了鲍勃一枚硬币。对。我还想指出这把折叠刀有多漂亮。
Beautiful. It's engraved with the letter CM. It's got this ivory handle. I found this on blademagazine.com. The knife was made by a Canadian knife maker named Brian Little. He described it as a gentleman's piece in an old time style, but large enough for use as a tool to make traps and spears
太漂亮了。上面刻着字母CM。它有个象牙柄。我在blademagazine.com上找到了这个。这把刀是由一个名叫布赖恩·利ittle的加拿大制刀师制作的。他将其描述为一个老派风格的绅士物件，但尺寸足够大，可以用作制作陷阱和长矛的工具
and for other survival needs. The letters C, M are of course for Charles Morse. But here's the thing I thought was interesting. Brian Little had worked on Legends of the Fall. With Anthony Hopkins. Yes, and Brad Pitt. And Brad Pitt liked his knives and actually bought some to give as gifts to the movie's cast, including Anthony Hopkins.
以及满足其他生存需求。字母C、M当然代表查尔斯·莫尔斯。但这里有个我觉得很有趣的事情。布赖恩·利特尔曾参与过《秋日传奇》的制作。和安东尼·霍普金斯合作过。是的，还有布拉德·皮特。布拉德·皮特很喜欢他的刀，实际上还买了一些作为礼物送给电影的演员，包括安东尼·霍普金斯。
When it came time to select the knives for the edge, the assistant props master brought along Little's knives during a meeting with all the movie officials, which Anthony Hopkins attended. And he saw the blades and recognized the maker's name on them. Wow. There's pictures of Brian Little on the set with this article. I'll include it in our stories. He also was the person that engraved both watches,
当轮到为《边缘》挑选刀具时，助理道具师在与所有电影官员开会时带上了利特尔的刀，安东尼·霍普金斯也出席了那次会议。他看到了刀刃，并认出了上面制作者的名字。哇。这篇文章里有布赖恩·利特尔在片场的照片。我会把它收录到我们的故事里。他也是给两块表刻字的人，
because he was also an engraver. And he passed away in 2016, but his legacy lives on. That's beautiful. I love that they used this artist. Yeah. This specialty knife maker on this film. But I have a nagging question. Did Brad Pitt give Anthony Hopkins a penny?
因为他也是个雕刻师。他在2016年去世了，但他的传奇长存。太美妙了。我很高兴他们用了这位艺术家。是的。在这部电影中使用了这位专业制刀师。但我有一个挥之不去的问题。布拉德·皮特给安东尼·霍普金斯一枚便士了吗？
Are they still friends? This we don't know. If I ever meet Brad Pitt or Anthony Hopkins, that's the question I'm gonna ask. I'm gonna be so confused. I hope you lead with it. I will. I hope you say, Brad, I know you gave everyone knives
他们现在还是朋友吗？这个我们不得而知。如果我能遇到布拉德·皮特或安东尼·霍普金斯，这就是我要问的问题。我会超级困惑的。我希望你单刀直入。我会的。我希望你会说，布拉德，我知道你把布赖恩·利特尔制作的刀
as a gift by Brian Little, the Canadian knife maker. Did you also include a coin? Yep. Yeah, I hope I'm with you the day you ask him that. Do I lead with that or do I lead with funny story? Sometimes I have a dream that you make me soup. Oh God. I don't know which one.
作为礼物送给了每个人，他是那个加拿大制刀师。你当时也塞了一枚硬币进去吗？没错。是啊，我希望你问他那句话的时候我在你身边。我是该直奔主题还是先讲个有趣的故事？有时我做梦梦见你给我做汤。噢天哪。我不知道选哪个。
No, you have to lead with that one. Okay, we're also both from Missouri. There's so much for me to talk to Brad Pitt about now. Gosh, you're not gonna talk his ear off if you ever meet him. Why have we not met? I don't know. I don't know. Well, as soon as they do this gift exchange,
不，你得先讲那个。好吧，我们俩也都是密苏里人。现在我和布拉德·皮特有那么多可聊的了。天哪，如果你真遇到他，你可别一直唠叨个没完。为什么我们还没见过？我不知道。我不知道。好吧，他们一做完这个礼物交换，
everybody who's doing the photography shoot is like, guys, we gotta get up early tomorrow, let's go to bed. And they just leave. And the only person left behind is Styles, Krusty Styles and Charles. They have another sort of 90 second conversation, and now it's bedtime for everybody. The next day, Charles is reading his survival book
所有负责拍照的人就说，伙计们，我们明天得早起，去睡觉吧。然后他们就走了。唯一留下来的人是斯泰尔斯、讨厌的斯泰尔斯和查尔斯。他们又进行了大约90秒的对话，现在大家都该睡觉了。第二天，查尔斯在读他的求生书，
and the photo shoot is happening, but Bob says it's lame. This is a lame photo shoot. There's more flirty banter though between Bob and Mickey. Yep, they do these sort of cockney accents and she's like, should I sunbathe on this beach nude? And he's like, sorry lady, it's against the rules. What are they doing? They are flirting right in front of Charles. I know. He gives her a peck on the cheek.
拍照正在进行，但鲍勃说这太逊了。这次拍摄太逊了。不过鲍勃和米奇之间有更多调情的打趣。没错，他们学着伦敦东区下层阶级的口音，米奇说，我是不是应该在这片海滩上裸体日光浴？鲍勃说，对不起，小姐，这违反规定。他们在干什么？他们就在查尔斯面前打情骂俏。我知道。他在她脸颊上轻轻亲了一下。
Yeah, but she blows him an air kiss. So I guess it's okay? I don't know. Okay. Well, we have what I'm calling creepy Krusty Styles moment. Okay. As Charles is going through his book, he opens to a page with a Kodiak bear, and Krusty Stiles says, Kodiak bear, soon kill you as look at you. And the ones that's killed a man is a man hunter for the rest of his life. Nothing he'd rather eat got the taste of human flesh. A man-killing machine.
对，但她给他隔空飞了个吻。所以我想这没问题？我不知道。好吧。嗯，接下来是被称为“令人毛骨悚然的讨厌斯泰尔斯时刻”。好吧。当查尔斯翻看他的书时，他翻到了一页科迪亚克熊，讨厌的斯泰尔斯说，科迪亚克熊，看见你就要杀了你。杀过人的熊一辈子都是人猎手。没有它更想吃的东西，它尝过人肉的味道。一台杀人机器。
Yeah. That is creepy. It is. Is everybody keeping up with this? Here's what we need to keep our eye on. We need to keep our eye on these watches. We need to keep our eye on man-killing bear. Bear that has a taste for man. Yeah. keep our eye on these watches. We need to keep our eye on man-killing bear, bear that has a taste for man.
对。这真让人毛骨悚然。确实。大家都跟上节奏了吗？这是我们需要密切关注的。我们需要密切关注这些手表。我们需要密切关注杀人熊。那头尝过人肉滋味的熊。对。密切关注这些手表。我们需要密切关注杀人熊，那头尝过人肉滋味的熊。
Also, don't forget, we are worried about migrating birds. That's gonna come up in a second. Well now Bob is really pissed because apparently nothing on this photo shoot is going his way. I guess there's some shoes that look really sh**y, they need to be shined. Charles of course pipes in with some trivia. He says use a banana peel. I looked it up, it's true. You can shine shoes with a banana
还有，别忘了，我们还在担心候鸟。这待会儿就会提到。好了，现在鲍勃真的很生气，因为显然这次拍照什么都不顺他的意。我猜有些鞋子看起来太破了，需要擦一下。查尔斯当然插话抖了一些冷知识。他说用香蕉皮。我查过了，这是真的。你可以用香蕉皮
peel. Charles, I mean, I can't imagine him on a road trip. He's got so much trivia. You do not need to look up anything Charles says. It's all true. It's all true. And then also Bob finds out that his model, James, is sick, like really sick. Yes, the male model. He can't participate. So Bob says, that his model James is sick, like really sick. He can't do the shoot. Yes, the male model. Yeah. He can't participate, so Bob says, I need Jack Hawk. That's it.
擦鞋。查尔斯，我的意思是，我无法想象他去公路旅行。他有太多的冷知识了。你根本不需要去查证查尔斯说的话。全都是真的。全都是真的。然后鲍勃还发现他的模特詹姆斯病了，病得很重。是的，那个男模特。他不能参加。所以鲍勃说，他的模特詹姆斯病了，病得很重。他不能参加拍摄。是的，那个男模特。对。他没法参加，所以鲍勃说，我需要杰克·霍克。就是他。
Okay, that's who I need. We're going to get in this prop plane. We're going to go to his cabin. It's 80 miles north with no phone or radio. I mean, I'm out. They got to go, and they say, Charles, come with us. Let's go on an adventure. Charles is like, sure, I'm in.
好吧，这就是我需要的人。我们要坐这架小型道具飞机。我们要去他的木屋。那是80英里以北的地方，没有电话或无线电。我的意思是，我可不干。他们必须得走，而且他们说，查尔斯，跟我们一起去吧。去冒险吧。查尔斯说，当然，算我一个。
Here's why they're doing this. Now, in this movie, Charles is gonna drop a lot of wisdom. I have four wisdom moments that I'm gonna point out as we break down this film. Bob has one and it's right here. Here's the one piece of advice in life that I think you can take from Bob. What is it?
他们为什么要这么做呢。在这部电影中，查尔斯将抛出许多人生大智慧。在我剖析这部电影时，我有四个充满智慧的时刻要指出来。鲍勃有一个，就在这里。这是我认为你可以从鲍勃身上学到的人生忠告中的一条。是什么？
Steven says, should we really do this? Is this a good idea? Like, should we go fly and get this guy? And Bob says, a good plan today is better than the perfect plan tomorrow. I have that in bold. Yeah. Which is another way of saying, why put it off? Just do it.
史蒂芬说，我们真的要这么做吗？这主意好吗？比如说，我们应该去开飞机把这家伙接来吗？鲍勃说，今天的良好计划胜过明天的完美计划。我把这句话加粗了。是的。换句话说，为什么要拖延？做就对了。
Get it done. Get it done. And you know what? Charles is probably ready to go. I mean, Mickey's like, get some air under your wings. And then also Styles has hit him up for about 30 to $40 million to build like a resort. That's right. So he's like, I'm out.
把它干完。把它干完。你知道吗？查尔斯可能已经准备好出发了。米奇说，让你的翅膀呼吸点新鲜空气吧。然后斯泰尔斯还向他索要三四千万美元来建个度假村什么的。没错。所以他心想，我溜了。
We do find out that they're gonna lose light at 4.18 PM. They gotta get going. So they get on the plane. They're heading out. they're gonna lose light at 4 18 p.m. They got to get going. So they get on the plane. They're heading out. They're heading out. I do have a classic Bob snark moment as they take off on the plane. Oh yeah? I want to play it. All right. Can I tell you something Charles? Yeah if you like. I admire the way you took that joke last night. Huh? Handled well. Embarrassing moment, I thought you handled it well.
我们确实发现他们将在下午4点18分失去光线。他们得抓紧了。所以他们上了飞机。他们出发了。他们将在下午4点18分失去光线。他们得抓紧了。所以他们上了飞机。他们出发了。他们出发了。当飞机起飞时，我确实有一个经典的鲍勃冷嘲热讽时刻。哦是吗？我想放出来听听。好的。查尔斯，我能跟你说件事吗？行，如果你想说的话。我很佩服你昨晚处理那个笑话的方式。啊？处理得很好。挺尴尬的时刻，我觉得你处理得很好。
Thank you. Tough road a hoe you think about. That's some snark right there. That's like, oh, I was so embarrassed for you, but you handled it great. How embarrassing for you though, you fell down. Gosh, that was embarrassing, but you did fantastic. Yeah.
谢谢你。想想看，这日子可真够难熬的。这绝对是冷嘲热讽。就像是，哦，我当时为你感到太尴尬了，但你处理得真棒。不过你摔倒的样子真尴尬。天哪，那太尴尬了，但你表现得太出色了。对。
Such snark. Yeah. Also, I do want to adopt how Charles responds to someone wanting to tell them something. What did he say? Say, I wanna tell you something. I wanna tell you something. Yeah, if you like.
太讽刺了。是的。另外，我很想学学查尔斯对别人说想告诉他某事时的回应。他说什么来着？说，我想告诉你件事。我想告诉你件事。对，如果你想说的话。
All right, so there's some great dialogue. It goes on. What you played, Angela, it goes on. Bob says, I bet it's really hard to have all that money. Yeah. People always coming at you. You never know why people really want to be around you. And then Charles says, never feel sorry for a man who owns a plane. It's a great line. Bob loves it.
好吧，所以有一些很棒的对话。还在继续。安吉拉，你放的这段，还在继续。鲍勃说，我敢打赌，拥有那么多钱一定很难。是的。人们总是朝你涌来。你永远不知道人们为什么真的想和你在一起。然后查尔斯说，永远不要为一个拥有飞机的人感到难过。这台词太棒了。鲍勃很喜欢。
Loves it. Thought that was so funny. And then Charles looks at Bob and says, so, how are you planning to kill me? And then right after he says that, all the birds fly into the plane and the pilot is like, s***, hold on!
超喜欢。觉得这太搞笑了。然后查尔斯看着鲍勃说，那么，你打算怎么杀我？就在他说完这话之后，所有的鸟都撞向了飞机，飞行员说，操，抓紧！
Oh yeah. It's so dramatic. And the plane and the pilot is like, s***, hold on. Oh yeah. It's so dramatic. And the plane goes down. It plummets like down the edge of a cliff and then it crashes into the lake. I found a video on how they did this crash. It is so fascinating because this is before, this is 1996 everybody.
哦，是的。太戏剧性了。然后飞机和飞行员说，操，抓紧。哦，是的。太戏剧性了。飞机坠落了。它像悬崖边缘一样垂直坠落，然后撞进了湖里。我找到了一个关于他们如何拍摄这场坠机戏的视频。太迷人了，因为这是在以前，这是1996年，各位。
This isn't like... It's before like all the special effects-y stuff, right? Yes, before all the CGI stuff. Now, first of all, these geese that fly into the plane window and get in the propeller and cause it to jam up and then make the plane go down, they were added digitally in post. But to get this crash,
这可不是那种……这比所有那些特效都要早，对吧？是的，在所有CGI特效出现之前。现在，首先，这些撞进飞机窗户、卷入螺旋桨导致卡住并让飞机坠毁的大雁，是在后期通过数字技术添加的。但为了拍出这场坠机，
they basically built a giant zip line from the top of the mountain over the lake down to the other side of the shore. And they attached the plane to the zip line and then they made it crash into the lake. The video shows how they tested it. They like crazy. But I want you to hear how the shoot day went. So they tested it one day, and then they put the plane up there, and they got ready to shoot it. Here's a clip.
他们基本上从山顶跨过湖泊一直到岸的另一边，建了一条巨大的滑索。他们把飞机系在滑索上，然后让它撞进湖里。视频展示了他们是如何测试的。他们像疯了一样。但我想让你们听听拍摄当天的情况。所以他们有一天测试了它，然后把飞机放在那里，准备拍摄。这是一个片段。
At five o'clock in the morning, the crew returns to prep the plane for its brief flight. Mannequins are placed inside the cockpit to sit in for the actors. The plane is loaded onto a transport boat and brought out to the rig where it's attached to the cables. The wings and pontoon are pre-cut or scored to make sure they tear off cleanly. That's it. We got it. Once it's secured to the rig, the crew clears the area in preparation for the big moment.
清晨五点，剧组返回，为飞机的短暂飞行做准备。驾驶舱内放置了人体模型来代替演员。飞机被装上一艘运输船，带到安装有缆绳的钻塔上。机翼和浮筒都预先被切割或划了痕，以确保它们能干净利落地撕裂脱落。就是这样。我们成功了。一旦固定在钻塔上，剧组就会清理该区域，为这重要时刻做准备。
But before any action takes place, a safety meeting is held to outline procedures for the crash. Now, in terms of safety, the area which is the most dangerous is 150 foot either side of the bollards holding the lines to the plane. Did you hear that? It was a safety meeting. I love it. I mean, that's a big safety meeting. Oh yeah. And I'll send you the link.
但在任何动作开始之前，会举行一次安全会议，概述坠机事故的程序。现在，就安全性而言，最危险的区域是固定飞机缆绳的桩柱两侧各150英尺的范围。你们听到了吗？这是一次安全会议。我太喜欢了。我的意思是，这是一次大型安全会议。哦，是的。我会把链接发给你们。
If anyone wants to watch this, you can watch this stunt. You can watch the whole safety meeting. I'll put it in our stories. They went on to say that they had six cameras set up to get the plane crash. Remember when we broke down speed and we learned about how they jumped the bus and they had all the cameras? All right, well, they set up the six cameras, they did a take, and the director didn't think it looked dramatic enough.
如果有人想看，你可以看这个特技。你可以看整个安全会议。我会把它放进我们的故事里。他们接着说，他们设置了六台摄像机来拍摄飞机坠毁。还记得当我们剖析《生死时速》时，我们了解到他们是如何飞跃公交车的，他们设置了所有摄像机吗？好吧，他们设置了六台摄像机，拍了一条，但导演觉得看起来不够戏剧性。
Oh. And I got it. When you see it in the video, it's kind of like they've clearly like they're making it so that it comes down real slow down this zip line. The director was like, I don't know, it looked kind of lame. So he's like, I want to do a second take. First, they had to get the broken plane out of the lake. They only had one plane. This isn't speed with their like 13 buses.
哦。我懂了。当你在视频中看到它时，有点像是他们明显让飞机沿着这条滑索非常缓慢地降落。导演当时觉得，我不知道，看起来有点逊。所以他说，我想再拍一条。首先，他们必须把撞毁的飞机从湖里弄出来。他们只有一架飞机。这可不是拥有13辆公交车的《生死时速》。
They had one plane. They had to reassemble the plane overnight and then they did another take the next morning and it worked and what they did was they put no resistance on the zip line the second time. They just fully let gravity take that plane off the top of the mountain. It's so dramatic.
他们只有一架飞机。他们连夜重新组装了飞机，第二天早上又拍了一次，成功了。他们所做的是在第二次时对滑索不施加任何阻力。他们完全让重力把飞机从山顶带下来。太戏剧性了。
It's an amazing special effect. So many departments had to come together to work on that. So many. This video is really cool. But okay, so back to the movie, where are we? Well, we're underwater. The plane has submerged. The pilot looks like he died on impact. Bob, I want to point out, swims to the surface alone. He seemed like he tried to take note of his surroundings
这是一个了不起的特效。这么多部门不得不齐心协力来完成那项工作。太多了。这个视频真的很酷。好吧，回到电影，我们现在在哪？嗯，我们在水下。飞机已经淹没。飞行员看起来在撞击时就死了。我想指出的是，鲍勃独自游向了水面。他似乎试图观察周围环境，
and he very quickly was like, I'm saving myself. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He didn't stick around that long. No. He noted that the pilot, the one guy he probably needs is dead. And then he's like, I'm out.
然后他非常迅速地决定：我要自救。对。对。对。他没有在那里多待。是的。他注意到飞行员——他最需要的那个家伙——已经死了。然后他心想，我溜了。
These two guys are on their own. Yeah. Charles uses his knife, swims over to Steve, and cuts his seat belt, because Stephen is stuck, he can't get out, and then he grabs the bag of flares, very smart, they swim to the surface, and his survival book floats away. But he's already read it, I want to point out.
这两个人得靠自己了。是的。查尔斯用他的刀，游向史蒂夫，割断了他的安全带，因为史蒂芬被卡住了，出不去，然后他抓起那袋信号弹，非常聪明，他们游到水面，而他的求生书漂走了。但我想要指出的是，他已经读过了。
End to end? He doesn't need it. I don't know. It probably would be good to have, but also Charles remembers everything. But you know what they probably would have used it for? Fire. Not reading, fire.
从头到尾？他不需要它。我不知道。有它可能会好点，不过查尔斯也什么都记得。但你知道他们本来可以用它来做什么吗？生火。不是阅读，是生火。
Yeah. Charles and Bob now drag Steven to safety on the shore, and Charles has to do CPR on Steven, and finally he comes to, and they're all just freezing. Freezing. They get up kind of higher up the shoreline and they're trying to figure out how they can start a fire.
对。查尔斯和鲍勃现在把史蒂芬拖到岸上安全的地方，查尔斯不得不对史蒂芬进行心肺复苏，最后他醒了过来，他们全都冻僵了。冻僵了。他们爬到岸边地势较高的地方，试图弄清楚他们该如何生火。
Yeah, they're trying to light a fire with some matches and they just can't get it to start and Bob is like, f*** it. And he takes one of the flares and he like shoots it into the brush that they've brought together and the fire starts immediately. And Charles is like, we really maybe save those for
对，他们试着用火柴生火，但就是点不着，鲍勃火了，说，操。他抓起一颗信号弹，把它射向他们搜集到一起的灌木丛中，火立刻就着了。查尔斯说，我们其实也许应该留着它们，
when we need to signal for aircraft. But you know what, I'm going to allow this for Bob, because they are shaking, they are shivering. That is a sign of hypothermia. I know this from my cold dipping. If you're ever cold dipping and you start to shiver, you're supposed to get out. dipping. If you're ever cold dipping and you start to shiver, you're supposed to get out. And so they did need to warm up fast. So I think they using one of their three flares for this purpose, I'm gonna give them a pass. Yeah, Bob does have a moment where I got real pissed off at him. Why happens a lot for me. But he shares that he took the note from the cabin door. Oh my gosh, we forgot this plot point, lady.
等我们需要发求救信号时再用。不过你知道吗，对于鲍勃的这种做法，我表示理解，因为他们浑身发抖，瑟瑟发抖。那是低体温症的迹象。我从我的冷水浸泡经验中知道这一点。如果你在进行冷水浸泡时开始发抖，你就该上岸了。浸泡。如果你在进行冷水浸泡时开始发抖，你就该上岸了。所以他们确实需要快点暖和起来。因此我觉得他们为了这个目的用掉三个信号弹中的一个，我给他们开个绿灯。对，鲍勃确实有一个让我真的很生气的时刻。为什么这种情况总发生在我身上。但他透露他把木屋门上的字条拿走了。噢天哪，女士们，我们把这个情节给忘了。
So first of all, they get in that plane, they fly to find the guy and he's gone hunting. He left a note on his door that he went hunting, he says where, and they're like, oh, let's go find him where he's hunting. These guys are crazy. So yeah, they go even further into the wilderness. Right. They're now way away from where anyone would think they
所以首先，他们上了那架飞机，飞去寻找那个家伙，结果他去打猎了。他在门上留了条说他去打猎了，还写了地点，然后他们就想，哦，去找他打猎的地方吧。这些家伙真是疯了。所以是的，他们更深入荒野了。没错。他们现在离任何人会认为他们
would be. Yeah. But Charles thinks well maybe they'll know to come look for us this deep because of the note. Remember the note on the door where the guy said I'm going deeper into the woods? Yeah. And Bob goes oh and he opens his jacket and he's like I took the note. Why would he take the man's note? Yeah. Why? All right. So fine he used the flare, boo that he took the note. Also, another boo, Bob's gonna let the fire go out overnight. Bob. Yeah. Fire died. They survived the night, but there's no more fire. There's no more fire. Here's the thing. Bob is the reason they went deeper into the woods. Yeah.
会去的地方十万八千里。是的。但查尔斯认为，也许因为有字条，他们会知道这么深入来找我们。还记得门上的字条吗，那家伙说我往树林深处去了？对。然后鲍勃说，哦，他打开夹克说，我把字条拿走了。他为什么要拿那家伙的字条？对。为什么？好吧。所以好吧，他用了信号弹，鄙视他拿了字条。还有，另一个鄙视的点，鲍勃竟然让火在夜里熄灭了。鲍勃。对。火熄灭了。他们熬过了一夜，但再也没有火了。再也没有火了。问题是这样的。鲍勃是他们深入树林的原因。对。
Bob took the note, so now no one knows where they are. Bob used one of the flares. Then he let the fire go out. Yeah. He also would have left Stephen to die. Yeah. All true. All true. Well, now they're going to gonna start to wonder how are they getting out of here? Because no one knows where to look for them. They're gonna have to walk back. They have to figure out which way is south because they need to walk south to try to get back to where they started where people might be looking for them. But Charles is gonna have to convince these guys and here we have wisdom moment number one.
鲍勃拿走了字条，所以现在没人知道他们在哪里。鲍勃用掉了一颗信号弹。然后他还让火熄灭了。对。他甚至会把史蒂芬留在那里等死。对。全都是事实。全都是事实。好了，现在他们开始琢磨怎么离开这里了。因为没人知道该去哪里找他们。他们只能走回去。他们必须弄清楚哪个方向是南方，因为他们需要向南走，试图回到他们开始的地方，那里可能有人在找他们。但查尔斯必须说服这些人，这里有我们的人生智慧时刻一。
This is your first moment of wisdom in the movie The Edge. And I want you to hear it. I once read an interesting book. It said that most people lost in the wilds, they die of shame. What? Yeah. See, they die of shame. What did I do wrong? How could I have gotten myself into this? And so they sit there and they die because they didn't do the one thing which would have saved their lives. And what is that, Charles? Thinking. Yeah. Okay, so listen.
这是你在电影《边缘》中的第一个智慧时刻。我想让你听听。我曾经读过一本有趣的书。书中说，大多数在荒野中迷路的人，都是死于羞耻。什么？是的。你看，他们死于羞耻。我做错了什么？我怎么会把自己搞到这种境地？于是他们就坐在那里等死，因为他们没有做那件本可以救命的事。查尔斯，那是什么事？思考。对。好吧，所以听着。
Obviously, this is wisdom because it is a metaphor. It is not just about being in the wilderness. This is about when we are faced with any challenge in life. We can sit and give up and stew in how did I get myself into this position? Why is this happening to me? A woe is me? Or we can think ourself out of this situation, we can put our mind to it, and we can get out. Wisdom moment. Wisdom moment. Don't be a victim. Be active. Yes. Be a doer. Be a doer. Well you know Charles is gonna try to determine which way is south because that's the way they need
很明显，这是智慧之谈，因为它是一个隐喻。这不仅关乎身处荒野。这关乎当我们面临生活中任何挑战时。我们可以坐下来放弃，纠结于我怎么会陷入这种境地？为什么这种事会发生在我身上？怨天尤人？或者我们可以通过思考摆脱困境，我们可以动脑筋，然后我们就能走出去。智慧时刻。智慧时刻。不要当受害者。要主动。是的。要做一个行动派。要做一个行动派。好了，你知道查尔斯会试图确定哪个方向是南方，因为那是他们需要
to go to get back to where someone might be looking for them and he realizes his watch is broken and he asks Bob hey can I can I look at your watch? Bob crosses his arms like a toddler and goes mine's broken too. Shady Shady Bob. That's what I'm calling him. Charles is now gonna make a compass using a paperclip and a leaf. Bob is like, Charles, what are you doing?
去寻找可能在找他们的人的方向，他发现他的表坏了，他问鲍勃，嘿，我能，我能看一眼你的表吗？鲍勃像个幼儿一样双臂抱胸说，我的也坏了。可疑的，可疑的鲍勃。这就是我给他的称呼。查尔斯现在要用一个回形针和一片叶子做一个指南针。鲍勃说，查尔斯，你在干什么？
But they kind of follow him along anyway. Yeah, he rubs the paperclip on some silk, I guess his sweater or his shirt, and then he puts it on a leaf on some water and it pulls into a direction and he's like there it is. He says that the magnet of the earth will point it north and we're just gonna head the other way. Yeah. Well, I have a moment that I'm calling is Charles Yoda. Okay. He says the following, just because you're lost doesn't mean
但他们还是跟着他往前走。对，他在一些丝绸上——我猜是他的毛衣或衬衫——摩擦回形针，然后把它放在水面上的一片叶子上，它指向了一个方向，他说，就是这个。他说地球的磁场会指引它向北，我们只要往相反的方向走就行了。好吧，我有一个时刻称之为“查尔斯是尤达吗”。好吧。他说，仅仅因为你迷路了并不意味着
to say that your compass is broken. Oh I love it. Can't you hear Yoda saying that? Yes I can. The three men are now making their way through this rough terrain. They're heading south. There's like this jagged rocky mountain pass And then Charles decides to tell a random story about the Vikings. I thought you should hear it. You know the Vikings would steer their ship with a rope. A rope? How did they do that, Charles? Well, they'd have these two set points on the land they'd left behind or sailed away from. And they'd line them up and that would be their bearing.
你的指南针坏了。噢，我太喜欢了。难道你听不到尤达说这话的声音吗？是的，我能听到。这三个人现在正艰难地穿过这片崎岖的地形。他们正向南走。这里有像锯齿状的岩石山隘，然后查尔斯决定讲一个关于维京人的随机故事。我觉得你们应该听听。你知道维京人会用一根绳子来掌舵吗？一根绳子？他们是怎么做到的，查尔斯？嗯，他们会在他们身后离开或航行离开的陆地上设定两个基准点。然后他们把它们连成一线，那就是他们的方位。
And then they'd trail this long rope behind the ship, pointing at those two points, the hill or whatever. You might want to conserve your breath. That's a Bob snark. Bob is like, we're hiking up this thing. We're lost in the woods. Would you shut up about the Vikings? So we have some Bob snark. But I wanted to play this clip because I feel like Charles is a combination of Dwight, Yoda, and Cliff Claven from Cheers. Yes. Yes, very much so. Well, now luckily they come upon a waterfall and they can have some water. Yeah, because they have no food or water. That's the other thing.
接着他们把这根长长的绳子拖在船后，对准那两个点，比如山丘什么的。你也许该省点力气。那是鲍勃的冷嘲热讽。鲍勃的意思是，我们正艰难地爬着这玩意儿。我们在树林里迷路了。你能闭嘴不谈维京人吗？所以我们有一些鲍勃式的冷嘲热讽。但我想播放这个片段，因为我觉得查尔斯是德怀特、尤达和《干杯》里的克利夫·克拉文的结合体。是的。是的，非常像。好吧，现在幸运的是他们遇到了一个瀑布，可以喝点水了。是的，因为他们没有食物或水。这是另一回事。
Yeah, they haven't eaten. This is the first time we've seen them drink water. And now they're going to keep walking and now Bob is going to circle back and ask Charles, what was up with that comment on the plane about like how I'm going to kill you? What did you mean by that? Why would I want to kill you, Charles? And Charles says, my wife. He says, I've seen the two of you together. Yeah. Bob's like, why would I want to antagonize such a powerful man? I can get my own girls. And then Charles says, maybe you want the money. Mm-hmm.
对。他们还没吃过东西。这是我们第一次看到他们喝水。现在他们要继续前行，然后鲍勃回过头来问查尔斯，飞机上那个关于“我打算怎么杀你”的评论到底是怎么回事？你那是什么意思？我为什么要杀你，查尔斯？查尔斯说，我妻子。他说，我见过你们俩在一起的样子。是的。鲍勃说，我为什么要招惹这么有权势的人？我自己能泡到妹子。然后查尔斯说，也许你想要这笔钱。嗯哼。
And then Bob laughs and he's like, oh man, the rich really are different. You just think everybody loves your money. Even though I keep bringing it up. Exactly. They're gonna keep walking, they're gonna keep walking. Charles has some more trivia. Yes. Everyone is in a pretty good mood. Mm-hmm more trivia. Yes. Everyone is in a pretty good mood. All things considered. All things considered until they hear a very unsettling noise. Yeah. It's a f***ing bear. It's a Kodiak bear. Mm-hmm. Bob and Steven, they bug out of there. Charles looks the bear right in the eye.
然后鲍勃笑了，他说，哦天哪，有钱人果真不一样。你总觉得每个人都爱你的钱。尽管我一直在提起它。没错。他们继续往前走，继续往前走。查尔斯还有更多的冷知识。是的。大家的心情都挺不错的。嗯哼，更多的冷知识。是的。大家的心情都挺不错的。考虑到种种情况。考虑到种种情况，直到他们听到一个非常让人不安的声音。对。是一头他妈的熊。是一头科迪亚克熊。嗯哼。鲍勃和史蒂芬吓得拔腿就跑。查尔斯直视着熊的眼睛。
He does what Krusty Stiles said to do. And then he slowly backs up, but then they start running and they are running man for their lives and the bear is chasing them and all I could think about in this scene was the thing that Josh always tells me which is you only have to outrun one person. Well the person in the rear is Charles. Yeah, they all, they get this giant log to cross over the stream and the other two go across it and Charles is trying to go across it. This is terrifying. This log is up high. It's narrow. And the bear comes up and starts pounding on the log trying to get him to fall off. Yeah, I wanna shout out the production designer,
他照着讨厌的斯泰尔斯说的那样做。然后他慢慢后退，但接着他们开始逃跑，他们拼了老命地奔跑，熊在后面追他们，这个场景中我脑子里想的只有乔斯总是告诉我的一件事，那就是你只需要跑得比一个人快就行了。好吧，落在最后的人是查尔斯。对，他们所有人，他们找到一根巨大的原木准备过河，另外两个人过去了，而查尔斯正试图过去。这太吓人了。这根原木很高。很窄。熊走过来，开始猛拍原木，想让他摔下去。是的，我要向布景设计师
Wolf Kroger and the locations manager, Rhino Pace. This whole chase scene through the woods, it's down an embankment, it's into the water. I mean, this was an amazing location and set design. Like amazing. Yeah. Should we also talk about our new main character that has entered the film, the bear?
沃尔夫·克勒格和外景经理莱诺·佩斯致敬。整个在树林里的追逐戏，从斜坡冲下来，冲进水里，我的天，这是一个了不起的外景和布景设计。简直绝了。是的。我们是不是也该谈谈我们的新主角，也就是进入电影的这头熊？
Yeah. All right, the bear in the movie was played by the very famous Bart the Bear. He was a Kodiak brown bear subspecies from an island on the coast of Alaska. This is where many bears grow to be quite enormous. However, he frequently played an inland brown bear. It's very rare for an inland bear to be the size of Bart.
对。好吧，电影里的熊是由非常著名的“大熊巴特”扮演的。他是阿拉斯加海岸一个岛屿上的科迪亚克棕熊亚种。这里的许多熊都能长得非常庞大。然而，他经常扮演内陆棕熊。内陆熊能长到巴特这么大是非常罕见的。
He weighed over 1,700 pounds as an adult. Bart has an impressive resume. You mentioned Legends of the Fall, Angela. Bart was in Legends of the Fall. He had worked with Anthony Hopkins before. Bart was so well-trained that he could be commanded to do things like stand up on his hind legs, charge toward actors, and even swim without needing much prompting from his handler or trainers.
成年后他的体重超过了1700磅。巴特有着令人印象深刻的履历。安吉拉，你提到了《秋日传奇》，巴特出演了《秋日传奇》。他以前和安东尼·霍普金斯合作过。巴特受过极好的训练，以至于可以指挥他做一些事情，比如用后腿站立、向演员冲锋，甚至在不需要驯兽师太多提示的情况下游泳。
Alec Baldwin was extremely impressed with how well-trained and docile Bart was. And here he is describing what it was like to work with him. The bear thing is done very carefully, and it's very kind of sterile how it's done for safety reasons. So when you do it, there isn't a lot of danger involved. I mean, they bring the bear out and you sit there and go, wow, it's this famous movie bear. How are you today?
亚历克·鲍德温对巴特训练有素且温顺的程度印象极其深刻。这是他描述与巴特合作时的感受。与熊的合作非常小心，出于安全原因，整个过程非常规范。所以当你拍摄时，涉及的危险并不多。我的意思是，他们把熊带出来，你坐在那里心想，哇，这是那头著名的电影熊。你今天怎么样？
Nice to see you. And then the thing gets up on all fours, that was kind of striking. I wasn't prepared for how enormous this thing is. I mean, it's like, I don't know what it is, nine feet tall or 11 feet tall or some ridiculous thing. It's like the size of a tree. But the interesting thing is that it's all done very cautiously when you're shooting and there's not a lot of really danger involved. And they go off and they piece it together and cut it and do sound editing and things like that to make it. So when I saw the film, I thought, wow, you know, they really, really got made this
很高兴见到你。然后那家伙四肢着地站了起来，这挺震撼的。我没有准备好这东西到底有多庞大。我的意思是，这就像，我不知道它有多高，九英尺高还是十一英尺高，或者一些离谱的数字。它就像一棵树那么大。但有趣的是，拍摄时一切都非常谨慎，并没有真正涉及多少危险。他们把镜头拍下来，然后拼凑剪辑，做声音编辑之类的来完成它。所以当我看到这部电影时，我想，哇，他们真的把这个场景
look very, very harrowing and very frightening. Yeah, Alec Baldwin went on to say that he was actually concerned that it wouldn't look scary enough because of how docile the bear was while they were shooting and When he saw the final film Alec Baldwin said that Bart should send the film editor a fruit basket for making him look so scary He did look scary. Mm-hmm trainers Doug and Lynn Seuss said that Anthony Hopkins was quote, absolutely brilliant with Bart.
拍得非常非常惊心动魄，非常可怕。是的，亚历克·鲍德温接着说，他其实很担心它看起来不够吓人，因为熊在拍摄时太温顺了。当他看到最终的成片时，亚历克·鲍德温说巴特应该给电影剪辑师送一篮水果，感谢他把自己剪得这么吓人。它看起来确实很吓人。嗯哼，驯兽师道格和林·苏斯说，安东尼·霍普金斯与巴特的合作可以说是“绝对的出色”。
Because he acknowledged and respected Bart like a fellow actor. That Anthony Hopkins would spend hours just looking at Bart, admiring him. And as a result, Anthony Hopkins did many of his own scenes with Bart. Well, I saw an interview with Anthony where he talks about acting with Bart the Bear, and I thought we should hear it. Yes, he's a real big, 1,500 pound killer. He was also in Legends of the Fall with Brad.
因为他像对待同行演员一样承认并尊重巴特。安东尼·霍普金斯会花上几个小时只是看着巴特，欣赏他。因此，安东尼·霍普金斯与巴特的许多戏份都是亲自上阵完成的。嗯，我看过一个安东尼的采访，他在采访中谈到了与熊巴特演戏的经历，我觉得我们应该听听。是的，他是个真正的、体重1500磅的大家伙，也是个杀手。他曾和布拉德一起出演《秋日传奇》。
He's a big animal, and he's a killer. He'll kill you if you get in his way. But he's been brilliantly trained by Doug Seuss and treated with great love and affection and respect. You can really hear in his voice the reverence that he has that this is a huge animal. Yep, that has been trained well, but I'm going to be respectful and just be careful. Yeah. Well, Bart died of cancer in 2000. At the age of 23, his trainers Doug and Lynn Seuss started the Vital Ground Foundation
他是个大动物，也是个杀手。如果你挡了他的路，他会杀了你的。但他得到了道格和林·苏斯出色的训练，并受到了极大的爱、关怀和尊重。你真的能从他的声音中听出他对这是一只庞大动物的敬畏。没错，它受过良好的训练，但我会保持尊重，小心行事。嗯，巴特于2000年因癌症去世。享年23岁，他的驯兽师道格和林·苏斯创立了“生命土地基金会”
in honor of Bart. It was an organization set up to help preserve land for great grizzlies and other wildlife. Oh, I love that. I know. Well, listen, you said that Bart the Bear was stomping on this tree limb that Charles is trying to cross. Charles is going to go in the water and so is the bag of flares. Yep. And then these other guys are going to have to go fish him out of the water.
为了纪念巴特。这是一个旨在帮助保护大灰熊和其他野生动物栖息地的组织。哦，我太喜欢这个了。我知道。好吧，听着，你刚才说熊巴特在踩着查尔斯正试图过河的那根树枝。查尔斯掉进水里了，那袋信号弹也是。没错。然后其他几个家伙不得不去水里把他捞上来。
Yeah. They escape the bear, but they lose the flares. That's right. And the bear looks down at them and is like ticked off and he roars. And here's a moment that I found incredibly frightening because that bear turns around real quick and leaves. And you know what? That is not a good sign. You don't think? Not in Kinsey Survival 101.
对。他们逃脱了熊的追捕，但弄丢了信号弹。没错。熊低头看着他们，气冲冲地咆哮着。这里有一个让我觉得极其可怕的时刻，因为那头熊非常迅速地转过身走了。你知道吗？这可不是什么好兆头。你觉得不是吗？在金斯利生存101中可不是这样。
In my opinion, you want that bear to be really mad and growl and growl and then slowly give up and be like, well, didn get him today no no no he does a hard pivot and runs the other way somewhere because you know what he knows another way to get him he's going around something he has not done that's what I think that means well I'm telling you you're gonna be right when I watched this the first time and I knew nothing about the movie when that bear turned around so fast, I was like, mm-hmm, he knows another way. Mm-hmm. Well, now the guys have to continue their journey. Charles is really beating himself up because he lost the flares. Right, this would be his moment of
依我看，你会希望那头熊气急败坏地咆哮，咆哮，然后慢慢放弃，心里想，好吧，今天没抓到他，不不不，他来了一个急转弯，朝别的什么地方跑去，因为你知道吗？他知道另一条能抓到他们的路，他要绕道做点什么。我敢肯定那是这个意思。好吧，我告诉你，你到时候就会明白了。我第一次看这部电影时，对电影一无所知，当那头熊转变得那么快时，我就想，嗯哼，他知道另一条路。嗯哼。好吧，现在这群人必须继续他们的旅程。查尔斯因为丢了信号弹而一直在狠狠地自责。没错，这就是他的
shame. Yes, and Bob reminds him shame is how people die in the woods. You got to let it go, Charles. Charles is very touched that Bob saved his life. And you know Bob jokes that he'd have to kill Stephen if he killed Charles and he really needs Stephen because Stephen knows how to make his coffee. Charles says how do you like your coffee? And Bob says I like my coffee how I like my women. And Stephen says bitter and murky. And then they laugh so hard. Yeah. And I wrote I'd be shitting myself. How can they be so jokey so quickly? Well, they're in shock. I think they're in shock. Yeah.
羞耻时刻。是的，鲍勃提醒他，羞耻是人在树林里丧命的原因。你得放下它，查尔斯。查尔斯非常感动，因为鲍勃救了他的命。而且你知道鲍勃开玩笑说，如果他杀了查尔斯，他就得杀了史蒂芬，他真的很需要史蒂芬，因为史蒂芬懂得怎么煮他的咖啡。查尔斯问，你喜欢怎么样的咖啡？鲍勃说，我喜欢咖啡就像我喜欢女人一样。史蒂芬说，又苦又浑浊。然后他们笑得前仰后合。是的。而我当时想，我要是他们，肯定吓得屁滚尿流了。他们怎么能这么快就开起玩笑来？好吧，他们处于休克状态。我觉得他们处于休克状态。是的。
They're going to have to camp out for the night. They make another fire. Again, they haven't eaten. Nope. And they don't have any water with them. No. The next morning, they're walking and guess what happens? They come upon their first campfire with the flare that they used and they realize they have just walked in a giant circle. Yeah. Well, Stephen starts to lose it. Yeah. He's convinced they're going to die out there. Right. They have no food.
他们得露营过夜。他们生了另一堆火。同样，他们还没吃过东西。没有。而且他们身上也没有任何水。没有。第二天早上，他们走着走着，你猜怎么着？他们遇到了他们用过的那颗信号弹留下的第一个篝火堆，他们意识到自己刚才转了个巨型大圈。是的。好吧，史蒂芬开始崩溃了。是的。他确信他们会在那儿死掉。没错。他们没有食物。
They haven't eaten. So Charles is gonna give them a knife, tell them to make a spear. I want you to listen because this is wisdom moment number two from Charles. See this? Gonna make a spear. All right. You want me to make a f***ing spear? Yeah.
他们没吃东西。所以查尔斯要给他们一把刀，让他们做一支长矛。我希望你们听听，因为这是查尔斯的人生智慧时刻二。看到这个了吗？要做一支长矛。好吧。你想让我做一把他妈的长矛？对。我们需要你做一把他妈的长矛？对。我们需要你做一把用来钓鱼的。来，拿着这个。来，拿着。很好。行吧，好吗？
We need you to make a f***ing spear? Yeah. We need you to make one for fishing. Go on, take that. Go on, take it. Good. Fine. Okay?
我们需要你做一把他妈的矛？对。我们需要你做一把用来钓鱼的。来，拿着这个。快拿着。很好。行。可以吗？
You can do that. They'll never find us. They will find us, Steve, and even if they don't, we're gonna walk out of here. You do as I say now, okay? I'm gonna make a fire Come on get on with it It's gonna be okay Here is the piece that I missed I missed this the first 15 times I watched this movie
你可以做到的。他们绝对找不到我们。他们会找到我们的，史蒂夫，就算他们找不到，我们也要从这里走出去。现在听我的，好吗？我要生个火。得了吧，快点。会没事的。这里是我漏掉的一个片段。我看了这部电影前15遍时都没注意到这个
I'm gonna get emotional. So buckle in. I watched this movie last year after my breast cancer surgery, before I started chemo, and I was spiraling. And I thought, how am I gonna get through this? How am I gonna get through this? And I zeroed in on this part of the movie
我要情绪失控了。所以都坐稳了。我去年在做完乳腺癌手术后、开始化疗前看了这部电影，当时我的情绪正在崩溃。我想，我怎么才能熬过这一关？我怎么才能熬过这一关？然后我注意到了电影里的这个部分
when Charles says, we're gonna walk out of here. And now I'm getting choked up because I thought to myself, I'm going to get through this. I'm going to walk out of here. I am walking out of here. And I started walking every day, every single day. Sometimes I did circles in my backyard. Sometimes I walked around the whole
当查尔斯说，我们要从这里走出去。现在我哽咽了，因为当时我心里想，我能熬过这一关。我要从这里走出去。我正从这里走出去。于是我每天都开始走路，每一天都走。有时我在后院绕圈走。有时我绕着整个
block. Sometimes I went on full hikes. I went on a full three-mile hike at one point during chemo. I did what I could each day. It wasn't the same each day. But I held on to that. I thought, I am going to walk out of here. That's how I'm going to get through it. That's how I'm going to get out of here. And that is why I love this movie so much. I love it so much. Because to me, that was like, that was my like moment. And I just wanted to lay in bed all day. And I just wanted to feel all my side effects. And I just wanted to, I really thought, I don't know how I keep on keeping on this year. Yeah. You know, but that was a moment for me where I had to decide.
街区走。有时我会去进行完整的徒步。化疗期间我有一次甚至去进行了一次完整的三英里徒步。我每天尽力而为。每天的情况都不一样。但我抓住了那个信念。我想，我要从这里走出去。这就是我熬过难关的方式。这就是我离开这里的方式。这就是我为什么这么喜欢这部电影。我太喜欢它了。因为对我来说，这就好像是，这就是我的高光时刻。而我当时只想整天躺在床上。我只想感受我所有的副作用。我甚至想，我真的在想，我不知道今年我该怎么坚持下去。是的。你知道的，但那对我来说是一个必须做出决定的时刻。
Right. I had to decide, what am I waiting for? No one can do this but me. Right. And how am I gonna be during this journey? Yeah. I remember you left me a message. Yeah.
没错。我必须决定，我在等什么？除了我自己，没人能做到这一点。没错。在这段旅程中我要以什么状态度过？是的。我记得你给我留过言。是的。
And you're like, Angie, I'm gonna walk out of this. I'm literally going to walk. And it was like an emotional decision and a physicality that you took on as well to sort of bolden the emotional resolve. And you did, you would walk and I was just, I was, man, I was amazed, Jenna, at your grit.
你说，安吉，我要从这里走出去。我真的要走出去。这不仅是一个情感上的决定，你还付诸了体力上的行动，以此来增强内心的决心。而你确实做到了，你会去走路，而我真的，真的感到很惊讶，珍娜，佩服你的毅力。
One foot in front of the other. And like I said, sometimes it was a five minute circle in my backyard. Yeah, but you did it. But I walked every day. And that did something to my mental resolve. Yeah. And you know, my cancer nurse, Nurse Ron, who I love, he encouraged me to get up out of bed each day and have some kind of activity. He said he's been a cancer nurse
脚踏实地，一步一个脚印。就像我说的，有时只是在后院绕着走五分钟。是的，但你做到了。但我每天都走路。这增强了我的心理抗压能力。是的。你知道的，我的癌症护士，罗恩护士，我非常喜欢他，他鼓励我每天起床活动活动，做点运动。他说他当癌症护士
for, my gosh, 25, 30 years. And he said, in my experience, the women who keep moving, they do better. They just do better. He's so sweet. He was like, he was like, so I don't want you to go in and draw those curtains and stay in bed. Draw those curtains. I love that so much. The idea that I was just gonna draw my curtains. He was like, I want you to throw up in those curtains. I want you to get sunlight each day. I want you to get fresh air each day. And I want you to walk just a little bit each day. And so when I saw this movie, I thought, yeah, that's right, I'm gonna walk out of this. Just like Nurse Ron and just like Charles tells us to.
已经有，天呐，25、30年了。他说，以我的经验，那些保持活动的女性，情况会更好。她们就是会恢复得更好。他太温柔了。他当时说，他就像是，所以我才不想让你去拉上那些窗帘然后一直躺在床上。拉开那些窗帘。我太喜欢这个了。那种我只会去拉上窗帘的想法。他当时就说，我希望你在那些窗帘上吐。我希望你每天都能晒到太阳。我希望你每天都能呼吸到新鲜空气。我希望你每天都稍微走一走。所以当我看到这部电影时，我想，是的，说得对，我要从这里走出去。就像罗恩护士说的那样，也像查尔斯告诉我们的那样。
I'm so glad you're sharing all of that, Jenna. This is all stuff I knew. It's also another reason I really wanted to watch this movie because I knew on a deeper level how it spoke to you in that moment. It did. And you know, in the scene, there's more dialogue where Bob is questioning Charles as well.
我很高兴你分享了这些，珍娜。这些其实我都知道。这也是我真的很想看这部电影的另一个原因，因为我更深刻地知道它在那个时刻是如何触动你的。确实如此。你知道的，在那个场景中，还有更多的对话，鲍勃也在质疑查尔斯。
And I wanted to point out this is the first time we see Charles raise his voice. He's been so mild-mannered with everything going on. But this is the first time he seems slightly agitated and he says to Bob, what would you like to do, huh? Should we lay down and die? And then he raises his voice. He's like, should we lay down and die, Bob? Bob apologizes.
我想指出的是，这是我们第一次看到查尔斯提高音量。面对发生的一切，他一直都温文尔雅。但这是他第一次显得有些烦躁，他对鲍勃说，你想怎么做，嗯？难道我们要躺在这里等死吗？接着他提高了音量。他说，难道我们要躺在这里等死吗，鲍勃？鲍勃道歉了。
But I thought it was important to point out, this is the first moment Charles is getting worked up. Yeah. Well, now something's going to happen. Oh, we hear a scream, like a pure pain yell. Yeah, Stephen, while he was making his spear, has cut his leg like deep. Yeah, the minute I saw this, I thought, well, he's dead.
但我认为有必要指出，这是查尔斯情绪开始激动的第一个时刻。对。好吧，接下来要发生事情了。哦，我们听到了一声尖叫，那种纯粹痛苦的惨叫。是的，史蒂芬在制作他的长矛时，把腿割得很深。对，我看到这一幕的时候，就想，好吧，他死定了。
Charles is gonna stay calm at this very bloody leg. He's like, you're gonna be fine, you're gonna be fine. He puts a bandana around it, he ties it tightly, and then night falls and Charles has made like a little lean-to structure that they can all. That they're all sitting under. And he's like, you know what, I think you're gonna be fine because it was a clean cut.
面对这个满是鲜血的腿，查尔斯依然保持镇定。他说，你会没事的，你会没事的。他在上面缠了一块大手帕，系得很紧，然后夜幕降临，查尔斯搭建了一个小型的靠壁庇护所，他们都可以。他们都坐在下面。他说，你知道吗，我觉得你会没事的，因为那是一个干净的切口。
And Steven thanks Charles. He's like, you know what, you're all right. You're a very thoughtful man. And Charles appreciates that. And Charles like, you know what? We're gonna get out of here. He points to a constellation and says, that's Cassiopeia. And he says, we're gonna walk south
史蒂芬感谢了查尔斯。他说，你知道吗，你人挺不错的。你是个非常体贴的人。查尔斯很感激这一点。查尔斯就像是，你知道吗？我们要离开这里。他指着一个星座说，那是仙后座。他说，我们要向南走
through the river to safety. And as Stephen falls asleep, he says, how do people die in the woods? And Charles says, shame. Yes, that's right. So we're not gonna blame ourselves for cutting our leg and making it harder for all of us to get out of the woods. We're just gonna move on.
穿过河流到达安全地带。当史蒂芬睡着时，他喃喃自语道，人们在树林里是怎么死的？查尔斯说，羞耻。是的，没错。所以我们不会因为割伤了腿、给我们所有人走出树林增加难度而责怪自己。我们只会继续前行。
That's right. Okay, we're all fine. This is just no biggie. And now Charles leaves a sleeping Stephen. He goes to wash his hands in the lake. How do you wash your hands in a lake? Do you wade into the lake? He walked into the lake.
没错。好吧，我们都很好。这根本不算什么。接着，查尔斯留下了熟睡的史蒂芬。他去湖边洗手。你怎么会在湖里洗手？你要蹚水进湖里吗？他走进了湖里。
There is no reason for him to get his feet wet. It is cold out. Why? Bob is having a smoke. He looks out at the view. He says, this all puts things in perspective. It's a little different from the fashion world. A little different from snorting coke off girls' hip bones.
他根本没有理由弄湿自己的脚。外面很冷。为什么？鲍勃在抽烟。他望着远处的风景。他说，这一切让人有了新的视角。这和时尚界有点不同。和从女孩臀骨上吸可卡因有点不同。
And then Charles says, how so? I know. And they have a good laugh. They do, and then Bob gets up and walks in the lake. Why? I did not notice this. They both now have wet feet at night. Bad idea.
然后查尔斯说，怎么说？我知道。然后他们开怀大笑。他们确实笑了，接着鲍勃站起来走进了湖里。为什么？我竟然没注意到这一点。他们俩现在大晚上的脚都湿了。这主意真烂。
This is very upsetting to me. I often have cold feet at night. Well, it wouldn't have mattered if they walked in the lake or not. They're gonna have cold wet feet. Because just like in an episode of Survivor, when you think this day can't get any worse, it's going to start pouring rain. Pouring. Downpour. Yes. They're freezing. They're shivering. Mm-hmm.
这让我觉得很沮丧。我晚上经常脚冷。好吧，他们走不走湖水其实都无所谓。他们的脚都会又冷又湿。因为就像在《幸存者》的一集里一样，当你觉得这一天不可能再糟糕的时候，开始倾盆大雨了。倾盆大雨。暴雨。是的。他们冻僵了。他们在发抖。嗯哼。
Charles, once again, is like, listen, we're freezing, they're shivering. Charles once again is like, listen, we're going to get out of here. And then he notices the bloodstained pant leg. Okay, so when they made the tourniquet for Stephen's leg, they cut off part of his bloody clothes, and Charles explicitly says, Bob, go bury this. Right? It's got blood on it. It's like-
查尔斯再次说道，听着，我们冻僵了，他们在发抖。查尔斯再次说道，听着，我们要离开这里。然后他注意到了那条沾满血迹的裤腿。好吧，当他们为史蒂芬的腿做止血带时，他们剪掉了他沾血衣服的一部分，查尔斯明确地说，鲍勃，去把这个埋了。对吧？上面有血。这就像——
Bury it. Bury it. What did Bob do? He hung it from a tree. He threw it up in a tree. Why? Why? It's just like blowing in the wind,
埋了它。埋了它。鲍勃做了什么？他把它挂在了一棵树上。他把它扔到了一棵树上。为什么？为什么？它就在风中飘扬，
just this blood smell going through the air. I wrote, I hate Bob. And Bob's like, what's the big deal? I'll do it later. And Charles is like, you're putting the scent of blood in the air. The bear is going to smell that. And Bob's like, whatever. No sooner does Bob dismiss this idea than a bear comes barreling out of the woods. The same bear.
这血腥味在空气中弥漫。我写道，我讨厌鲍勃。鲍勃却说，有什么大不了的？我待会儿再弄。查尔斯却说，你这是把血腥味散发到空气中。熊会闻到的。鲍勃却说，随便啦。鲍勃刚说完这话没多久，一头熊就从树林里冲了出来。还是那只熊。
And eats Stephen. Just brutally attacks him. Brutally attacks him. I want to point out, Bob hauls ass pretty quick. Charles stays behind and tries to throw logs at the bear. And you know what though? There's no saving Stephen. He's literally getting picked up, upside down, torn apart.
然后吃掉了史蒂芬。遭到残酷的袭击。遭到残酷的袭击。我想指出的是，鲍勃溜得可真快。查尔斯留了下来，试图向熊扔圆木。你知道吗？根本救不了史蒂芬。他直接被抓起来，倒挂着，撕成了碎片。
Charles sees it all. How do you come back from that? That would haunt me for the rest of my life. We got a fan letter from Melissa P. in Ohio who said, the edge made me literally retreat downstairs the first time I watched it during the bear bit. Oh my gosh. I'm sorry, Melissa.
查尔斯目睹了这一切。这怎么能走得出来？这会让我余生都挥之不去。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州的梅丽莎·P.的粉丝来信，她说，第一次看这一集时，熊咬人的那一幕直接把我吓得退到了楼下。哦天哪。对不起，梅丽莎。
This is a great bear attack scene. It's not my favorite bear attack scene. How do you, I'm sorry, Melissa. This is a great bear attack scene. It's not my favorite bear attack scene. How do you, I'm sorry. How, why do you have a list of bear attack scenes? Who are you? Well, why do they keep putting them in movies? What other movies? I don't watch movies with bear attacks.
这是一个极棒的熊袭击场景。这不是我最喜欢的熊袭击场景。你怎么，对不起，梅丽莎。这是一个极棒的熊袭击场景。这不是我最喜欢的熊袭击场景。你怎么，对不起。怎么，你为什么会有一份熊袭击场景的清单？你到底是谁？好吧，为什么他们总把它拍进电影里？还有什么别的电影？我不看有熊袭击情节的电影。
The Revenant. Oh yeah, I'm not seeing that. I will never see that. Sam Cassie, have you seen The Revenant? I yeah, I'm not seeing that. I will never see that. Sam Cassie, have you seen The Revenant? I have, it's incredible. Incredible. It is the edge times 10. Yes it is.
《荒野猎人》。哦对，我可不看那个。我绝对不会看那个。萨姆·卡西，你看过《荒野猎人》吗？我，是的，我才不看那个。我绝对不会看那个。萨姆·卡西，你看过《荒野猎人》吗？我看过，太精彩了。太精彩了。简直是《边缘生死恋》乘以10倍。确实是的。
No thank you. It's everything that the edge has, but even more, more harrowing, more survival, more cold water, more bear attack. I can't take it. But without the sort of like, it doesn't have the what Sam? It's not uplifting in any way.
不用了，谢谢。它具备《边缘生死恋》的一切元素，但更夸张，更揪心，更多求生桥段，更多冰冷刺骨的水，更多熊的袭击。我承受不了。但却没有那种，它没有那种，萨姆什么？它一点也不励志。
Correct, that's what I was gonna say. There's no like wisdom. It's very dark. You mean there's no jokes about watches in two time zones? Ha ha ha! There's not. No one gets pranked at all. Nobody gets pranked in the remnant.
没错，这正是我要说的。没有任何人生哲理。非常黑暗。你是说没有关于两个时区手表的笑话？哈哈哈！没有。根本没人被整蛊。在《荒野猎人》里没有人被整蛊。
No thank you. Okay. Well, everyone, I think this is a good stopping place. This ends part one of our breakdown. Please join us next week to see how Charles and Bob go on from here. I got a hint for you. It's not gonna go great.
不用了，谢谢。好吧。各位，我觉得在这里停下来挺好的。我们这一部分的剧情解析到此结束。请大家下周继续收听，看看查尔斯和鲍勃接下来会遭遇什么。我给你们透个底。情况可不太妙。
It does not. And I will also be sharing the things you should and should not do during a real bear attack. You're gonna want to hear this. I thank you all for listening today and I hope you'll come back with us next week. This has just been a delightful, delightful, Galentine's Day gift. Angela, I thank you so much. You're welcome. It's gonna keep on going.
确实不妙。我还会分享在真正的熊袭击事件中哪些事该做、哪些事不该做。你们一定得听听这个。感谢大家今天的收听，希望你们下周还能和我们一起来。这简直是一份美妙绝伦的情人节礼物。安吉拉，太感谢你了。不客气。精彩还在继续。
We'll see you next week. See you then. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
我们下周见。到时见。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Burman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. It's the sweetest time of year. That's right, Valentine's Day is approaching and Macy's has the best of the best gifts for your loved ones. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. I love shopping on Macy's.com.
我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。Audyssey的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉雅·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。一年中最甜蜜的时刻到了。没错，情人节即将来临，梅西百货为您挚爱的人准备了最好中的最好的礼物。这个情人节，让梅西百货成为您的送礼向导。我喜欢在Macy's.com上购物。
They really, really do have everything and their gift guide is amazing. I've gotten so many good ideas from the Macy's.com. They really, really do have everything. And their gift guide is amazing. I've gotten so many good ideas from the Macy's gift guide. I did probably 2 thirds of my Christmas shopping on Macy's.com this year. With my kids, we do a gift for Valentine's Day, a small gift, instead of candy. We don't do a lot of candy. There's been enough candy with Halloween and the Christmas
他们真的，真的什么都有，而且他们的送礼指南太棒了。我从Macy's.com上得到了好多好点子。他们真的，真的什么都有。而且他们的送礼指南太棒了。我从梅西百货的送礼指南中获得了好多好点子。今年我的圣诞节购物大约有三分之二是在Macy's.com上完成的。我和孩子们过情人节时，我们会送一件小礼物，而不是糖果。我们不怎么送糖果。万圣节、圣诞袜已经有够多糖果了
stocking and all of that, so when we get to Valentine's Day, I like to wrap up a little something for them. Macy's has got you covered for the adult loved one in your life and the kid loved one in your life. Shop Macy's gift guides for the perfect hand-picked items for everyone on your list. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Shop in store or online There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有其他零食，所以到了情人节，我喜欢为他们精心包装一个小礼物。梅西百货为您生活中成年的挚爱和年幼的挚爱都考虑周全了。选购梅西百货送礼指南，为名单上的每个人挑选完美的精选礼物。这个情人节，让梅西百货成为您的送礼向导。欢迎到店选购或在线购买。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。